Chào mừng các bạn đến với khóa học excel
miễn phí từ cơ bản đến nâng cao dành cho
người mới bắt đầu được thực hiện trên
kênh YouTube gà Excel bài số 24 record
macro các bạn sẽ mở cái file này lên nhé
bài học hôm nay gồm có hai phần đầu tiên
sẽ là giới thiệu về record macro thứ hai
là các ví dụ cơ bản và nâng cao ở đây
mình có ba ví dụ đây trong ví dụ đầu
tiên ấy Đây là một cái bảng mục lục Khi
mà mình tích vào dữ liệu 1 thì nó sẽ
nhảy về cái shit dữ liệu 1 Sau đó mình
tích vào đây mình quay về cái trang chủ
ở đây sau đó mình muốn chuyển về dữ liệu
3 chẳng hạn thì mình sẽ tích vào dữ liệu
3 đấy nó sẽ nhảy đến cái shit dữ liệu 3
ở đây sau đó các bạn tích vào Quay về
trang chủ các bạn có thể tích vào dữ
liệu ha trong ví dụ thứ hai mình giới
thiệu các bạn là các bạn sẽ nhập dữ liệu
tự động ở đây ví dụ đây là dữ liệu mà
các bạn sau khi nhập bây giờ Giả sử ta
nhập thêm một nhân viên mới nhá mã nhân
viên Ví dụ mình nhập là 4 đi Họ và tên
là gá Excel
kế hoạch ví dụ kế hoạch Doanh thu là 12
đô chẳng hạn mà mục tiêu ở đây là 15 đấy
các bạn tích vào nhập liệu đấy các bạn
chuyển sang cái shit data này Đấy mình
đã nhập thêm được cái nhân viên tiếp
theo là g Excel đấy ví dụ mình muốn nhập
nhân viên mới tiếp tục mình điền vào đây
mã nhân viên tiếp theo là số 5 chẳng hạn
tên là gì Excel chicken chẳng hạn nhá kế
hoạch gì ạ 100 đấy mục tiêu là 120 chẳng
hạn các bạn tích vào nhập liệu trong
trong cái shit data này đã nhập được tên
nhân viên thứ năm trong ví dụ tiếp theo
ấy Mình hướng dẫn các bạn là tìm kiếm
giả sử ở đây mình có danh sách các sinh
viên của một trường đại học Ví dụ mình
cần tìm bạn nào họ Nguyễn chẳng hạn nhá
Đấy thì các bạn tích vào gì ạ Tìm kiếm
nó sẽ trả về danh sách các cái bạn mà có
họ là Nguyễn Nguyễn Văn và Nguyễn Đức ở
đây Đấy Bây giờ ví dụ mình muốn tìm mới
nhá mình sẽ tích vào đây để mình xóa đi
giả sử mình tìm cái bạn nào giới tính là
con gái nhá Đấy thì các bạn sẽ tích vào
Tìm kiếm đấy nó sẽ ra danh sách cho các
bạn tất cả các bạn nữ ở đây ví dụ mình
tìm là con gái và tên là và có họ là
Nguyễn nhá mình sẽ xóa dữ liệu đi mình
tích vào tìm mới mình tìm là gọ Nguyễn
và điều kiện thứ hai là con gái đấy các
bạn sẽ tích vào tìm kiếm như vậy chỉ có
một bạn mà thỏa mãn điều kiện là họ mà
có họ là Nguyễn và giới tính là gái đấy
Ok Nào mình cùng bắt đầu bài học ngày
hôm nay
đây là file dữ liệu mà sau khi các bạn
đã tải về nhá các bạn chú ý nhé link tải
file để các bạn thực hành ở trong phần
mô tả phía dưới video nhá các bạn có thể
tích Vào link để các bạn tải về và các
bạn thực hành cùng mình record macro ấ
là một cái công cụ trong Excel để các
bạn làm quen với cả lập trình vba record
macro ấy thì nó sẽ giúp các bạn là nếu
như mà bạn không biết được cái lệnh nào
Ví dụ như là vl Cup mình sử dụng như như
thế nào thì các bạn có thể record nó rồi
các bạn sẽ xem được là cái cách để dùng
lệnh vl Cup hoặc là cách tô màu hoặc là
cách để các bạn filter thì các bạn đều
có thể record Sau đó các bạn sẽ biết
được là cách sử dụng thứ hai là với
những bạn mà không có khả năng lập trình
ấy thì các bạn hoàn toàn các bạn có thể
sử dụng record macro để các bạn tạo ra
được những cái công cụ mà như vừa nãy
mình đã chạy thử cho các bạn nhé thì đầu
tiên ý để dùng được record macro ấ thì
các bạn vào thẻ developer này các bạn
chú ý nhá Nếu như bạn nào mà không có
cái thẻ developer ấy thì các bạn các bạn
nháy chuột phải vào bất kỳ một cái vị
trí nào trên cái thanh ribon này các bạn
chọn customizer
ribon đấy thì trong cái Tab customize
ribon này Các bạn nhìn sang bên phải đây
này Nó có cái chữ developer đây này nếu
các bạn nào thấy trắng ấy thì các bạn
tích vào đây sau đó các bạn tích ok nhá
thì ở đây mình đã tích rồi thì thôi nhá
Đấy sau đó các bạn vào thẻ developer Các
bạn chọn record macro thì đầu tiên ý nó
sẽ hiện một cái thông báo ở đây là tên
macro các bạn cần đặt tên ở đây thì nó
để mặc định thì các bạn có thể đổi tên
là gì ạ ghi macro các bạn chú ý nhá tên
thì các bạn phải viết liền và không có
dấu thành phần thứ hai là cái phím tắt
mà các bạn có thể cần để các bạn tạo cho
cái macro này thì các bạn có thể đánh
hoặc không ạ thì thực sự thì trong Excel
nó có rất nhiều phím tắt thì nếu mà các
bạn đặt trùng ấy thì nó sẽ dẫn đến xung
đột và đôi khi nó sẽ chạy sai cho cả
macro và cả cái phím tắt kia nữa thì nếu
mà không thực sự cần thiết ấ thì các bạn
cũng không nên tạo phiếm Tắt ở
đây tiếp theo ấ là cái thành phần ở đây
thì có ba cái thành phần để mình lưu cái
macro này thì một là personal macro
workbook hai là new workbook tức là một
tạo file mới và thứ ba là Z workbook
thường thì mình sẽ chọn zbook Tức là cái
g macro này nó chỉ có tác dụng trên cái
file này thôi ở đây là cái mô tả thì các
bạn có thể mô tả bất kỳ các bạn gì Các
bạn muốn ạ ví dụ các bạn mô tả là học
này ghi macro trong Excel chẳng hạn
thế Ok mình tích vào ok thì sau khi các
bạn tích ok các bạn sẽ thấy ở đây nó sẽ
hiện một cái gọi là stop recording trong
trường hợp mà Nếu các bạn muốn dừng ghi
thì các bạn sẽ tích vào đây Hiện tại thì
mình đang ghi Ok mình sẽ mở cái cửa sổ
Visual basic cho các bạn dễ hiểu nha vây
mình thu nhỏ cái này lại thì sau khi mà
các bạn bấm record macro ấy thì ngay lập
tức ở bên Visual basic này cửa sổ đây nó
sẽ tạo ra một cái Module ở đây đây đấy
Ghi macro đây chính là cái tên mà lúc
nấy mình tạo và ở đây là cái ghi chú của
mình là gì ạ học ghi macro trong
Excel Giả sử bây giờ mình muốn tô Cái ô
này nhá tô chữ là bôi đậm đi thì các bạn
vào thẻ home các bạn cho Bôi đậm lên đấy
xong Ví dụ mình cho màu là màu xanh này
đi xong Bây giờ mình kẻ khung nữa đấy
các bạn sẽ thấy không Mỗi một cái lệnh
tương ứng ý thì ở đây nó sẽ sinh ra một
cái tập code ở đây ví dụ mình gạch dưới
nữa chẳng hạn nhá Đấy thì các bạn thấy
không ở ở đây là gì ạ underline Đây bây
giờ sang bên này nhá mình lại bỏ gạch
dưới đi đấy thì nó mất cái gạch dưới đi
đy underline đây tức là mỗi một cái thao
tác bên này thì tương ứng là cái g macro
nó sẽ tạo ra một cái tập Lệnh tương ứng
với cả cái thao tác ở đây bên này của
mình Ok bây giờ mình muốn sử dụng ứng
dụng của cái ghi macro cho các cái ô
tiếp theo ở bên này nhá thì mình làm như
thế nào Bây giờ mình sẽ dừng ghi nhá các
bạn vào thẻ developer các bạn tích vào
cái nút vuông đây này Ở đây mình Phóng
to ra các bạn tích vào đây để các bạn
dừng ghi hoặc các bạn có thể tích vào
cái nút này này để các bạn dừng ghi nhá
ở đây mình stop đấy sau khi mình stop
rồi thì như vậy mình đã có một cái macro
mới là ghi macro bây giờ mình sẽ tạo một
cái bom để mình chạy macro nhá đây các
bạn vào thẻ developer các bạn tích vào
Insert này đấy các bạn có thể tạo cái gì
đây bom ở đây để các bạn chạy nhá đây ví
dụ mình tạo bom ở đây là gì ạ Các bạn có
thể gán vào luôn và ghi macro đây này
đấy ở đây mình có thể đổi tên nhá các
bạn nháy chuột phải các bạn edit text đi
Đấy mình sẽ đổi tên là gì chạy chương
trình Ok đây các bạn nháy chuột phải nhá
thì nó các bạn kéo rộng cái này ra Hoặc
là các bạn có thể gì ạ Các bạn vào
Insert này các bạn chọn cái hình xave
đây này Mình sẽ chọn một cái hình đấy ở
hình này cũng được và Mình sẽ bấm và gì
ạ edit text mình cũng ghi là chạy chương
trình tức là các bạn có thể dùng cái này
để gán macro hoặc các bạn dùng cái kia
cũng đều được ạ Đấy ví dụ mình dùng cái
này mình nháy chuột phải assign macro
đấy thì hai cái nút này là tương đương
nhau tại vì cùng gán đến cái macro kia
nhá Đấy mình có thể bỏ cái này
đi ok Bây giờ mình chạy thử chương trình
nhá Thì trước khi chạy chương trình mình
sẽ clear format đi nhá mình vào ô này
mình clear đi Các bạn vào thẻ home này
xong mình vào clear các bạn clear format
đấy thì cái ô này đã clear rồi Tức là
cái dữ liệu ban đầu của mình Đây bây giờ
mình Bấm CH chương trình này đấy thì nó
mặc định là chỉ có cái ô này là bôi đậm
Thôi bây giờ mình muốn sửa là bây giờ
mình tích vào ô nào đấy mình chạy thì nó
các cái ô nó phải là có format giống Cái
ô này cơ thì các bạn làm như thế nào nhá
Bây giờ mình lại vào cái cửa sổ Visual
basic thì các bạn chú ý nhá cái ô D9
Selection đây này chính là Cái ô này tức
là tất cả cái Selection ở đây nó sẽ thay
bằng ô D9 Tức là nó chỉ có tác dụng
trong cái ô D9 thôi Thì bây giờ mình sẽ
bỏ cái lệnh này đi các bạn sẽ bấm cái
dấu nháy đơn ở trên này này Coi như nó
sẽ chuyển thành chú tích hoặc các bạn có
thể xóa đi nhá đều được bây giờ để chạy
được cái này như sau Bây giờ mình tích
vào ô này các bạn chỉ cần bấm vào chạy
chương trình thôi đấy thì thấy chưa tất
cả các cái dữ liệu đây đã được gì ạ Đổi
màu này kẻ khung đấy Bây giờ mình Bôi
đen hết tất cả Đây mình bấm chạy chương
trình đấy Tất Cả Cái ô này đã được tạo ở
đây đấy thì các bạn chỉ cần xóa cái
Selection một cái ô đầu tiên thôi là các
bạn sẽ có thể áp dụng được cho tất cả
các cái ô ở bên này Đấy là tính năng rất
là tuyệt vời của record macro nhá bây
giờ quay trở lại cái chương trình của
mình nhá Bây giờ mình phóng to lên mình
đóng có thể đóng cái này lại rồi Các bạn
phóng to này lên bây giờ giả sử ở đây
mình có ba cái shit dữ liệu của các
tháng đây dữ liệu một là dữ liệu của
tháng một dữ liệu hai là của tháng Hai
dữ liệu ba là của tháng 3 Đây là cửa sổ
main này cửa sổ chính để mình cần tạo
nhá thì đầu tiên các bạn sẽ vào Insert
này các bạn tạo một cái hình đây ví dụ
mình tạo một cái hình mới ở đây là gì
mình có thể đặt tên nha các bạn nháy
chuột phải các bạn edit text này mình sẽ
đặt là dữ liệu 1 chẳng hạn thế nhá các
bạn có thể đặt bất kỳ hoặc là dữ liệu
tháng một cũng được x các bạn co này lại
cho nó vừa cái khung này cho đẹp hoặc
các bạn tích đúp vào đây các bạn căn
giữa mình vào thẻ home nhá mình căn giữa
ở đây đấy Nhìn nó sẽ đẹp hơn bây giờ các
bạn giữ Ctrl và giữ chột trái các bạn
kéo xuống Tức là mình sẽ copy cái khung
này Đấy xong r các bạn giữ chuột trái và
giữ Ctrl các bạn kéo xuống đấy Bây giờ
mình sửa s cái Tech này là dữ liệu tháng
Hai sửa cái này là dữ liệu tháng 3 bây
giờ mình kẻ khung này chẳng hạn thế các
bạn có thể tô
màu ví dụ đây còn trên này nhá thì ở đây
mình sẽ ghi là gì ạ bảng mục lục này Bây
giờ các bạn sẽ bô đen Cái dữ liệu từ OC
đến of này cho mình xong các bạn nháy
chuột phải các bạn vào format sell trong
cái phần alignment đây này các bạn tích
vào cái phần đây Các bạn chọn Center
across Selection đấy thì nó sẽ chuyển về
giữa cái vùng mình lựa chọn đây nhìn rất
là đẹp ạ Ok cái này mình có thể tô màu
nhá Ví dụ mình cho màu đậm này đi chữ
động cho mục lục thì mình to lên đấy Ok
Bây giờ ta sẽ ghi một cái macro mới nhá
các bạn tích vào record macro này mình
sẽ đặt tên là gì ạ tháng 1 đấy các bạn
tích ok tức là khi mình tích vào đây thì
nó sẽ nhảy đến cái shit dữ liệu một ở
đây đấy thì các bạn sau khi các bạn
record nhá thì các bạn thấy không ngay
cái biểu tượng stop recording để các bạn
dừng Nếu các bạn muốn này thì các bạn
chỉ cần tích vào cái dữ liệu tháng một ở
đây đấy thì lập tức này Bây giờ mình mở
cái cửa sổ Visual basic để các bạn hiểu
nhá lập tức gì ạ cái shit dữ liệu tháng
1 ở đây đã được select đấy rất là đơn
giản thế thôi các bạn chỉ cần stop
recording đấy bây giờ quay được trở lại
cái cửa sổ main nhá thì các bạn nháy
chuột phải vào dữ liệu tháng 1 này các
bạn assign macro các bạn sẽ tích vào cái
gì ạ tháng 1 đấy như vậy bây giờ mình
chỉ cần tích vào dữ liệu tháng 1 ở đây
Đấy nó đã nhảy đến dữ liệu tháng th một
ở đây rồi Rất là hay cho các bạn ạ Thì
bây giờ mình sẽ tạo một cái bom ở đây để
mình sẽ quay lại cái cửa sổ main ở đây
nhá Thì mình cũng ghi một cái macro các
bạn tích vào record macro này thì ở đây
mình sẽ là gì ạ quay lại này các bạn sẽ
đặt là các bạn nhớ là viết liền nhá thì
mình có thể bấm shift trừ này quay lại
đấy quay lại main đi Tức là quay lại cái
cửa sổ chính nhá các bạn tích ok đấy thì
các bạn chỉ cần tích vào cái tháng Một
đây mình mở cái cửa sổ Visual basic cho
các bạn dễ hiểu nhá Đây này cái sub quay
lại main đây đã được tạo
ra bây giờ các bạn chỉ cần tích vào cái
main này này đấy thì nó sẽ lập tức nó
tạo một cái dòng lệnh mới là shit main
đã được select rất là dễ cho các bạn đấy
để các bạn hiểu thôi Bây giờ mình phóng
to lên các bạn stop nhá Đấy như vậy mình
đã ghi được một cái macro là quay lại
cái bên này rồi Bây giờ mình sang cái SH
dữ liệu tháng 1 mình sẽ tạo một cái bom
đây mình ghi là gì ạ Các bạn nháy chuột
phải các bạn edit text Mình ghi là gì ạ
quay lại quay lại home nhá thì mình có
thể bấm cái mũi tên này cho đẹp quay lại
mục lục chẳng hạn nhá đấy các bạn kéo
rộng cái này
ra ok các bạn chú ý nhá trong này các
bạn có thể chọn những cái hình mà các
bạn muốn Ví dụ mình chọn cái hình này đi
Nhìn nó đẹp hơn thì các bạn chỉ cần tích
vào cái quay mục lục này nó sẽ quay lại
Cửa sổ main Thì bây giờ mình sẽ gán nhá
các bạn nháy chuột phải vào đây các bạn
vào assign macro mình sẽ gán vào cái
macro lúc đấy mình ghi là quay lại main
này Đấy bây giờ các bạn tích vào đây Đấy
nó sẽ quay lại cái cửa sổ main ở đây cho
các bạn đấy tương tự cho các bạn nhá Bây
giờ mình ghi tháng hai nhá mình sẽ không
giải thích nữa nhá thì các bạn sẽ vào
developer các bạn record macro mình sẽ
đặt làở gì ạ tháng hai ok xong mình sẽ
tích vào cái shit dữ liệu 2 này thôi đấy
xong mình stop lại đấy như vậy mình đã
có một cái gọi là tháng hai rồi bây giờ
mình quay cửa sổ main mình gán này các
bạn nháy vào cái dữ liệu tháng hai mình
assign IDE vào cái shit tháng ha ở đây
ok thì ở cái shit dữ liệu 2 này mình
cũng tạo một cái bom nhá thì mình quay
lại các bạn quay lại dữ liệu một mình có
thể copy này nháy chuột phải copy mình
sang dữ liệu hai ở đây mình ctrl V hoặc
là mình nháy chuột phải mình p nhá p đây
dữ liệu 3 cũng thế mình nháy chuột phải
mình p luôn đấy
thì ở đây mình không cần tích nữa các
bạn tích vào đây nó đã quay lại mục lục
rồi dữ liệu 2 đây các bạn tích vào nó đã
tự quay lại mục lục cho các bạn rồi nhá
Đây bây giờ mình sẽ tích vào dữ liệu
tháng hai đấy các bạn sẽ thấy dữ liệu
tháng hai đây Bây giờ mình ghi cái dữ
liệu tháng ba nhá các bạn vào developer
mình record macro Mình ghi ở đây là gì ạ
tháng 3 đấy các bạn tích ok xong các bạn
tích vào dữ liệu tháng ba thôi Đấy xong
mình sẽ stop ghi lại Ok bây mình tích
vào đây để mình quay lại Cửa sổ main nhá
thì ở đây các bạn chỉ cần nháy chuột
phải này assign macro mình sẽ assign vào
tháng 3 đấy như vậy Xong bây giờ mình
tích vào dữ liệu tháng 3 đấy nhảy về
tháng 3 r các bạn quay lại tích vào
tháng hai đấy nó sẽ sang cái dữ liệu hai
mình tích vào quay lại dữ liệu 1 đây Các
bạn thấy không và shift 1 mình bấm quay
lại Ok sang ví dụ thứ hai là nâng cao
nhá thì bạn chú ý nhá ở đây là gì ạ Ở
đây là mình sẽ tạo cách để mình nhập dữ
liệu tự động đấy đấy các bạn chỉ cần
nhập tên dữ liệu vào đây thôi xong là
các bạn tích vào nhập dữ liệu thì nó sẽ
nhập dữ liệu mới vào đây cho các bạn thì
để làm việc này như sau nhá ở đây mình
tạo một cái bom trước đi Các bạn vào
Insert hoặc các bạn có thể vào developer
đây mình Insert cái bom vàở đây cũng
được Tùy các bạn nhá
Đấy mình chưa gán vội mình bấm cancel ở
đây ở đây mình nháy phải này mình vào
edit text đấy mình xóa cái này đi mình
sẽ gán là gì ạ cập nhật
đâ là chỉ là tên thôi các bạn có thể đặt
tên bất kỳ các bạn muốn nhá bây giờ Giả
sử ta nhập một nhân viên mới nhá là nhân
viên số này họ tên là g
Excel kế hoạch là 12 mục tiêu là 15 đấy
Bây giờ chúng ta làm cách nào để mình
tích vào CP nhật đây thì D liệ ở bên này
nó sẽ điền vào tiếp cái hàng tiếp theo
thì cái này khó ở cái ch là gì Các bạn
chú ý nhá khó cái ch mà khi bạn copy dữ
liệu vào đây thì nó sẽ nhảy đến cái ô
tiếp theo mà Nó không đè cái dữ liệu cũ
thì nó nâng cao ở chỗ đấy nhá thì đầu
tiên các bạn vẫn chọn record macro cho
mình ở đây mình sẽ đặt là gì ạ Ví dụ
mình đặt là gì cập nhật dữ liệu này đấy
các bạn tích vào ok thì đầu tiên các bạn
sẽ gì ạ Các bạn Bôi đen Cái phần này
xong các bạn copy các bạn nháy chuột
phải copy nhá sang cái shit data này này
đấy thì đầu tiên Các bạn nhớ là các bạn
tích vào cái ô đầu tiên cho mình ở đây
là ô B3 Tức là cái hàng đầu tiên cột đầu
tiên của mình nhá mình tích vào đây xong
các bạn giữ Ctrl và mũi ti tiên xuống
đấy xong các bạn sẽ chọn một cái là gì ạ
Các bạn tích vào cái use relative
reference này tức là để lần sau mình có
ấy thì nó sẽ tự động nó dịch xuống một
tích vào cái này khi các bạn tích xong
thì các bạn thấy biểu tượng đấy nó hơi
hơi thâm thâm nó mờ mờ đây này Đấy sau
các bạn ấn mũi tên xuống đấy ấn mũi tên
xuống xuống đây xong các bạn nháy chuột
phải này các bạn chọn p spal mình chọn
transpose transpose tức là gì mình sẽ
chuyển dữ liệu cột thành hàng hoặc là
hàng thành cột Tức là mình sẽ chuyển
ngược lại thì ở đây mình tích ok sau khi
mình tích ok xong ấy thì các bạn tích bỏ
cái you relative ref này Đấy xong mình
sẽ quay lại input đấy mình xóa cái dữ
liệu này đi Đấy Bây giờ mình sẽ stop ghi
nhá Đấy Bây giờ mình sẽ nháy chuột phải
vào cái bom này để mình gán macro này
assign macro mình sẽ gán vào cái macro
là cập nhật dữ liệu bây giờ mình Bây giờ
các bạn nhìn thấy ở đây nhá Đây có gà
Excel rồi đúng không Bây giờ mình ví dụ
cập nhật số 3 ở đây là gì Ví dụ đây là
Excel chicken
đây kế hoạch là ví dụ 20 mục tiêu là 10
Chẳng hạn bây giờ mình tích vào cập nhật
đấy các bạn thấy chưa ở đây nó sẽ xóa đi
và ở trong cái phần data này nó đã cập
nhật đến cái người thứ ba Ở đây bây giờ
ví dụ mình nhập người thứ tư nhá mã Thứ
tư này họ vào tên là gì ạ Nguyễn Văn A
đấy kế hoạch là gì kế hoạch là 9 mục
tiêu là 10 9 chẳng hạn đấy các bạn tích
vào cập nhật đấy sang cái data này đấy
các bạn thấy chưa đã cập nhật được nhân
viên thứ tư trong cái này các bạn rất
chú ý cho mình là mình phải sử dụng cái
e relative reference này đấy thì nó mới
có tác dụng nhá Còn cái Ctrl và mũi tiên
xuống ở đây ấ tức là khi cứ khi nào mình
có thêm một cái nhân viên mới thì mình
bấm Ctrl vào mũi tên xuống ở đây này thì
nó sẽ xuống đến cái hàng cuối cùng đấy
Sau đó thì mình sẽ sử dụng cái IR
relative này này để nó sẽ xuống cái ô
tiếp theo đấy là như thế đấy nhá tiếp
theo là mình sang ví dụ Cuối Cùng Ở đây
là tìm kiếm mình sẽ sử dụng là advan
filter Ok đây là dữ liệu ban đầu bây giờ
mình sẽ tạo table bằng cách Các bạn bấm
Ctrl t nhá Hoặc là các bạn tích vào
Insert này đấy các bạn tích vào table
đây Hoặc là các bạn bấm phím tắt là Ctrl
t ở đây này Đấy Ok thì nó sẽ mặc định nó
Bôi đen tất cả cái vùng dữ liệu này của
bạn là từ B2 đến j23 các bạn nhớ tích
chọn là My table head header nhá đấy các
bạn tích ok đấy sau khi các bạn tạo
table này Các bạn nhìn thấy chưa các bạn
có thể đổi cái hình mẫu cho nó
đẹp Sau đó thì mình sẽ đặt tên table nhá
Cái table 1 là tên mặc định thì mình có
thể đặt tên là gì ạ dữ liệu cũng được
đấy các bạn enter như vậy Mình có một
cái table là tên là dữ liệu rồi nhá Bây
giờ mình quay trở lại cái tìm kiếm thì
cái Advance filter các bạn chú ý nhá các
bạn phải làm trong cái shit tìm kiếm này
này Tại vì khi các bạn copy dữ liệu ấ nó
chỉ có tác dụng trong cái Active SH thôi
Đấy tức là mình làm ở shit nào thì mình
mới dùng được Advance filter để mình
chiết xuất ở trên shit đấy thì đầu tiên
nhá để làm Advance filter là đầu tiên
các bạn phải record macro này các bạn
vào developer này mình bấm record macro
mình sẽ đặt ở đây là gì ạ Mình sẽ đặt là
Advance filter đi Đấy mình sẽ đặt này
Advance enter tức là lọc nâng cao đấy
Đấy mình tích
ok thì đầu tiên các bạn tích vào đây nhá
tích vào cái ô dưới cái ô thông tin này
các bạn vào
Advance V các bạn tích ok này thì ở đây
trong cái list Range của mình ấy thì
mình tìm ở cái vùng danh sách thơi chứ
không phải là trong ở đây thì các bạn
tích vào đây xong mình sẽ quay lại danh
sách mình lựa chọn mình Bôi đen tất cả
đây nhá Khi các bạn Bôi đen Các bạn thấy
chưa ở đây nó sẽ đổi tên thành dữ liệu ô
Đấy tức là cái table của mình là ô và Đ
tích vào cái mũi tên này thì sang cái
phần thứ hai là cái tiêu chuẩn lọc nhá
thì các bạn đây này các bạn sẽ Bôi đen
cho mình cái tiêu đề và Bôi đen Cái hàng
dưới nữ nữa Tức là từ ô B B2 đến Ô j3
đấy
đấy tiếp theo là mình sẽ tích vào cái
copy to N đây này Đấy xong các bạn tích
vào cái ô copy to đây xong các bạn tích
vào cái ô kết quả ở dưới này Đấy tức là
sau khi mà nó Advance filter thì nó sẽ
copy dữ liệu và cái ô kết quả dưới này
hoặ bạn tích vào ok đấy thì như vậy là
nó sẽ copy Tất cả dữ liệu xuống dưới ở
đây Các bạn chú ý nhá vì ở đây là trắng
đâm ra nó sẽ copy toàn bộ dữ liệu đấy
Bây giờ mình sẽ quay trở lại cái
developer và mình stop ghi bây giờ mình
sẽ tạo cái bom ở đây để mình tích nhá
thì các bạn có thể vào Insert này Đấy
mình chọn cái bom vào
đây mình sẽ đặt nháy chuột phải các bạn
vào edit text này mình sẽ đặt là gì ạ
Tìm kiếm đi hay là lọc cũng được ạ Tìm
kiếm dữ liệu đấy
các bạn tích đúp này mình cho căn giữa
này đ mình cho căn giữa Ở đây
đy các bạn có thể vào format Mình đổi
cái hình này N các bạn mong muốn
nhá Ví dụ mình để cái hình này
đi ok Bây giờ các bạn nháy chuột phải
này các bạn assign macro mình sẽ gán vào
cái macro là Advance filter đây này Đấy
tức là khi mà mình không nhập gì ở đây ấ
thì nó sẽ in toàn bộ dữ liệu ở đây cho
các bạn bây giờ ví dụ mình tìm bây giờ
các bạn chú ý nhá mình phải tạo một cái
record macro để mình xóa cái dữ liệu ở
đây đi Tức là mình xóa dữ liệu cũ đi Nếu
mình muốn tìm mới nhá thì các bạn cũng
tạo đây các bạn giữ chuột trái này các
bạn giữ Ctrl và chuột trái các bạn kéo
xuống đây Đấy tức là mình sẽ tạo một cái
buttom mới hoặc các bạn kéo sang đây
cũng được đấy các bạn nháy chột phải
edit text đấy Mình sẽ ở đây mình ghi là
gì Xóa dữ liệu xóa dữ liệu cũ
này ok bây giờ mình sẽ tạo record một
cái macro để mình xóa dữ liệu cũ nhá thì
các bạn sẽ vào gì ạ developer mình
record macro này các bạn ghi ở đây là gì
ạ Xóa dữ
liệu liệu cũ đấy các bạn tích ok thì các
bạn sẽ bô đen ở đây này Bôi đen từ đầu
đến cuối tốt nhất là các bạn giữ Ctrl
shift rồi Các bạn bấm mũi tên xuống này
tức mình xóa đến hàng cuối cùng cho chắc
ho các bạn nháy chuột phải các bạn
Delete Mình sẽ chọn là intro ở đây Tức
là mình xóa hết tương tự ở đây các bạn
Bôi đen hết ở đây xong các bạn bấm delit
nhá bấm delit trên bàn phím này này Đấy
Xong bây giờ mình stop recording này Bây
giờ các bạn nháy truyệt phải này các bạn
gán
nhé Đấy mình sẽ gán vào gì nh xóa dữ
liệu Ok bây giờ Xong rồi nhá Bây giờ các
bạn tích vào tìm kiếm Nếu các bạn không
nhập dữ liệu gì Các bạn tích tìm kiếm
này Đấy nó sẽ ra ôn Ở đây bây giờ mình
tích vào xóa dữ liệu cũ đấy mất hết ở
đây bây giờ ví dụ mình tìm bạn giới tính
là trai đi tìm con trai xem có bao nhiêu
con trai các bạn tích vào tìm kiếm dữ
liệu đấy như vậy con trai của mình ở đây
là có bao nhiêu bạn 11 bạn Vậy mình xóa
dữ liệu cũ đi mình tìm là con gái đi
Chẳng hạn
nhá con gái này các bạn tích vào tìm
kiếm đấy con gái nó sẽ ra là bao nhiêu
bạn con gái có 10 bạn thôi bây mình xóa
dữ liệu đi bây gi Giả sử mình tìm con
gái này và họ là Nguyễn đi Đấy tức là nó
sẽ xảy ra đồng thời nhá thì có bao nhiêu
bạn đấy nó chỉ có một bạn thỏa mãn thôi
tức là Nguyễn Văn và y đây là Yến đâ con
gái các bạn xóa dữ liệu nhé bây giờ ví
dụ Các bạn muốn tìm cái bạn nào có tổng
điểm lớn hơn 5 chẳng hạn nhá Bây giờ
mình xóa đi thì mình chỉ cần ghi ở đây
là lớn hơn 5 Tức là mình sẽ tìm kiếm bạn
nào có tổng điểm lớn hơn 5 chẳng hạn đấy
các bạn tích Tìm kiếm đấy Ở đây tổng
điểm lớn hơn 5 thì có bao nhiêu bạn rất
là nhiều bạn 20 bạn lớn hơn 5m lớn hơn
năm và là gì ạ là nữ đi Chẳng hạn nhá À
gái đi bây giờ à các bạn phải xóa dữ
liệu nh ở đây mình sẽ tìm gì ạ Tổng điểm
là lớn hơn 5 này và điều kiện là giới
tính là nữ thì có bao nhiêu bạn ở đây là
gái chứ mình nhặt là gái trai gái
đấy đây mình tích vào tìm kiếm dữ liệu
đấy như vậy là giới tính là gái và tổng
điểm lớn hơn 5 là có chỉ có có chín bạn
thôi Ok như vậy là mình đã kết thúc bài
học ngày hôm nay ở đây cảm ơn các bạn đã
theo dõi các bạn nhớn đăng ký Kênh để
cập nhật video mới nhất của gà cũng như
chia sẻ để giúp mọi người cùng học Excel
nhé Xin chào và hẹn gặp lại
[âm nhạc]